corse ayez confiance dans la solidarité
nationale semaine noire dans la
sidérurgie entre 15000 et 20000
licenciements doivent être annoncés
encore un million et demi de
manifestants à téhéran des slogans plus
politique mais pas d'incident
un monsieur bonsoir les coupes sombres
dans la sidérurgie le brouillage de
raymond barre en corse le pcc
intellectuelle la première partie de ce
journal sera politique avec en exergue
ce qui s'est passé à l'assemblée ce
matin pour la deuxième fois en une
semaine le gouvernement était tenu en
échec sur un projet qu'il ne souhaitait
pas voir aboutir
c'est une proposition de loi d'origine
rpr et communistes et qui tend
essentiellement à interdire le
financement par les communautés
européennes de campagne publicitaire
pour l'élection de l'assemblée
européenne en juin poche le rpr et le pc
ont donc voté pour cette proposition qui
a été adopté contre l'avis de l'udf
le parti socialiste abstenant alors
avant de revenir avec daniel brême sur
cette conjonction de force entre
communistes et gaullistes va vous faire
écouter les arguments de leurs deux
porte parole michel debré d'abord dit du
colonne et toute émission toute prise de
position toute propagande même camouflé
en information qui émanerait d'un
organisme multinationales ne peuvent
être qantas et de partialité et cela
constitue une ingérence inadmissible
dans les affaires françaises
ils sont donc interdire une telle
ingérence pas seulement dans le temps
imparti à la campagne c'est à dire à
partir du début d'avril
mais dès à présent des sommes
considérables ont été détournées de leur
objet 12 milliards de centimes
il n'appartient en aucune façon aux
organes de la communauté de faire de la
propagande
il appartient en aucune façon à une
assemblée des communautés européennes de
subventionner de campagne électorale
c'est de l'argent dérobé et par
conséquent une violation des traités
nulle part il n'est écrit peu l'argent
pour lequel
les parlements nationaux accorder des
sommes importantes aux organes
communautaires doivent servir à d'autres
actions que des actions à caractère
économique et c'est ce qu'à propos donc
très serrée réaction maintenant du
président de groupe parlementaire de
l'udf roger chinaud qui s'est opposée à
cette proposition de loi sur ce plan la
voix de l'assemblée a voté avant la vie
un texte inapplicable et il n'est pas
convenable qu'il n'est pas convenable
parce que je ne vois pas pourquoi on ne
présenteraient pas l'opinion française
ce qu'à fait la communauté comment elle
fonctionne c'est purement et simplement
de la formation physique civique qui
refusaient et je trouve ça très dommage
au demeurant j'espère que le sénat
rattrapera ce texte alors sur le plan
européen je suis tenté de dire qu'il y a
des gens qui mènent des combats derrière
regard sur l'europe ce n'est pas le
premier ce n'est pas le dernier
mais finalement je sais que l'opinion en
france dans sa majorité souhaitent que
la construction européenne se développe
alors avec moi maintenant en direct du
parlement daniel brême alors à première
vue daniel on a l'impression que le rpa
rue à nouveau dans les brancards et l'a
13 dans tout ça oui même s'il s'en
défend dans un communiqué publié ce soir
effectivement une nouvelle faille s'est
ouverte dans la majorité
pour parvenir à ses fins et battre en
brèche la politique européenne du
président de la république il n'est pas
douteux que le rpr n'hésitera plus à
unir ses voix à celles du parti
communiste et comme porte parole il
avait choisi celui qui en son sein est
le plus intransigeant sont croisés
michel debré pour tous pour qui tout ce
qui vient de bruxelles est un peu et on
complément ce soir dans les couloirs
claude labbé le président du groupe a
donné un aperçu sur la stratégie future
du rpr et il nous a dit au fond un
référendum sur une france indépendante
serait un bon thème sous-entendu cela
permettrait de recueillir un bon
pourcentage de voix et à ce tableau
c'est ajouter ce soir une lettre de
jacques chirac une nouvelle aux milliers
de cadres il demande à ses cadres de se
rassembler de pour l'intérêt national et
ils leur demandent de répondre par écrit
qu'ils sont d'accord
derrière lui et se manière de les tester
un petit peu exactement et ce n'est pas
l'ouvert
dur d'un débat sur l'élargissement de la
communauté
vendredi vous le pensez qu'il va faire
baisser la température dans les couloirs
alors du côté du ps maintenant ils se
séparent des communistes mais ne veut
pas rejoindre lui dire oui ils ne
veulent surtout pas être accusés par
leurs alliés communistes d'être la roue
de secours du gouvernement
mais là encore les problèmes de
politique intérieure ne sont pas absents
des consciences et ils ont aussi ce soir
pour s'expliquer publié une longue
lettre de deux pages dans laquelle il
dénonce je cite l'hypocrisie qui a gagné
tout à coup le rpr qui jusqu'àlors
accepté comme le pc les sommes données
par la communauté au goût à strasbourg
laiterie les vrais qui critiquent aussi
le gouvernement en lui reprochant de ne
pas assurer lui même le financement de
la campagne
alors quand au projet en particulier
c'est pas fini car il y aura le passage
au sénat bien oui mais là il y a
plusieurs inconnues d'une part le pc et
le rpr sont en minorité au sénat donc le
texte qui sortira silva devant le sénat
sera tout à fait différent
le problème est de savoir s'il pourra
être inscrit à l'ordre du jour et là je
vous signale que nous risquons d'avoir
une session extraordinaire de deux jours
les 21 et 22 décembre mais là c'est le
conseil des ministres qui décidera et
bien sûr à l'occasion de ce vote sont
revenus en mémoire les propos de jacques
chirac dans sa lettre aux français à
propos de l'europe des propos que
l'ancien ministre olivier guichard a
jugé ce matin peut mesurer
pas de réaction pour l'instant du
premier ministre à ce vote auquel
s'était opposé son ministre de
l'intérieur christian bonnet il faut
dire que raymond barre est en corse
depuis hier soir une visite officielle
de 48 heures qui a commencé par banny
bonifacio que nous survolons en ce
moment le premier ministre est venu
faire le point des quarante et une
mesure qu'avait annoncé le chef de
l'état
son dernier voyage dans l'île jean-louis
lesaint
je voudrais tout d'abord souhaité aux
corses la paix civile
les actes odieux qui se produisent ici
ne sont pas dignes des traditions de
cette île la deuxième chose que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que nous devons
tous avoir espoir dans le développement
de l'accord ce développement économique
et social il est indispensable parce que
la corse est une île jeunes et c'est
l'avenir de la jeunesse que nous devons
préparer la troisième chose que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que vous devez
avoir confiance dans la solidarité
nationale vous avez dit monsieur le
maire que la corse et bonifacio étaient
français qui peut en douter d'entrée de
jeu le premier ministre a donc formulé
les trois voeux du gouvernement pour la
corse c3 de raymond barre les a rappelé
tout au long de cette première journée
de voyage toutefois à chaque étape le
premier ministre a insisté sur un
problème économique particulier ce matin
à bonifacio les risques de pollution à
porto vecchio les liaisons aériennes et
routière c'est à dire le désenclavement
du sud de l'île à sari d'orcino
l'agriculture est particulièrement
l'agriculture de montagne
enfin ajaccio les finances locales à
chaque fois quand des mesures n'ont pas
déjà été prises monsieur bart annoncé
qu'un effort particulier serait
entrepris par le gouvernement à
l'occasion de cette visite du premier
ministre à cgt la cfdt et la fédération
d'éducation nationale avait lancé un mot
d'ordre de grève est appelé à une
manifestation à ajaccio le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que les syndicats
n'ont été que modérément suivi en
revanche et ajaccio notamment raymond
barre a reçu un accueil chaleureux de la
part de la population
en fin d'après-midi le chef du
gouvernement avait rendez vous avec le
conseil régional de la corse à la
préfecture de région
l'occasion pour les élus de faire
entendre un certain nombre de
récriminations l'occasion pour monsieur
bart de dresser le bilan des 40 est une
mesure pour la corse annoncé par valéry
giscard d'estaing ici au mois de juin
dernier
la plupart des objectifs fixés sont en
cours de réalisation
tous seront atteints je vous en donne
l'assurance comme chef du gouvernement
ainsi se dessine une corde attachée à
son passé est confiante dans son avenir
dans une france moderne et paisible
d'autres entreprises seront nécessaires
d'autres projets seront à définir pour
la corse
comme pour notre pays le développement
sera une création continue pour la corse
nous entreprendrons ses projets après
avoir écouté vos avis et nous les
entreprendront avec vous la
manifestation dont parlait jean luc hees
elles viennent de se disloquer une
manifestation organisée à ajaccio donc
par les partis de gauche les syndicats
et les autonomistes de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée à nice nyon de la gauche
pavoise elle a percé hier une brèche
dans une municipalité qui lui étaient
fermés depuis 50 ans sa liste a en effet
emporté avec près de 51% des suffrages
le premier tour d'une élection partielle
dans l'un des trois secteurs de la ville
la liste soutenue par le maire jacques
médecin n'a obtenu qu'un peu moins de 44
% du suffrage
chaque médecin garde cependant la
majorité à l'intérieur de son conseil
municipal
dernier titre politique de la journée
les suites du dialogue du parti
communiste avec ces intellectuels à
vitry près de paris quatre cents
militants un discours de georges
marchais intégralement repris dans
l'humanité ce matin mais aussi noël
copain un huit clos assez difficile à
forcer le oui assez difficile a forcé
hier et avant-hier car tous les
participants étaient très discrets ce
que l'on sait quand même c'est que ces
quatre centres intellectuels réunis
autour de georges marchais après l'avoir
écouté se sont séparés en quatre groupes
avec des membres du bureau politique
non sans avoir obtenu qu il y est quand
même une réunion de synthèse et puis que
le compte-rendu soit publiée aujourd'hui
dans l'humanité on sait que la
discussion était passionnée qu'elle a
même été assez violente
monsieur marché monsieur paul laurent
ayant participé personnellement de façon
active et si vous voulez je vous donner
quelques échantillons monsieur balibar
philosophe a estimé que l'image de la
situation présentée par georges marchais
était paranoïaque
hélène parmelin écrivain a reproché à
l'humanité soit de jouer les pères
fouettards soin de rester là mais ce
genre et lunch tennis
rien un traité bernard marx de stalinien
c'est que lui a valu une vive réplique
de rené andrieu et puis un avocat
lyonnais hugo iannucci a décrit les
dirigeants du pc comme des hommes de
marbre colère de charles fiterman qui
lui a répliqué il n'y a pas d' assassin
d'assassins potentiels à la direction du
parti
il est vrai que j'ai essayé d'avoir
quelques confidences d hier et
aujourd'hui mais tout ce que je viens de
vous dire n'a rien de confidentiel on
peut le lire dans le compte rendu de
l'humanité d'aujourd'hui car il faut
dire qu'il ya pas une contestation mais
des contestations
oui et c'est peut-être une des
principales caractéristiques de cette
réunion c'est qu'il ya effectivement des
contestations extrêmement diverses non
seulement en ce qui concerne leur
intensité ce qui vraiment critique
l'ensemble du parti et compris
éventuellement sa ligne ce qui critique
les méthodes de vie démocratique dans le
parti ou ceux qui font des critiques
modéré tout en s'affirmant se libère de
la direction du parti alors un pas en
avant quand même estimé la plupart des
orateurs des participes oui la plupart
des patrons dire quand même que cette
réunion est très positif est que il
s'est sans doute passer quelque chose
il est irréversible prenons une image le
couvercle de la marmite a été soulevé et
beaucoup pensent qu'il ne sera plus
possible de remettre le couvercle sur la
marmite
mais certains quand même on la crainte
d'une sorte de choc retour qui ce type
qui pourrait se situer sur le point
suivant
on le verra peut-être ailleurs des
comité central de demain et d'après
demain le parti communiste la direction
pourrait dire vous avez bien vu qu'il
était possible de discuter à l'intérieur
du parti communiste par conséquent il
n'est plus question maintenant que des
intellectuels livrent leurs états d'âme
à l'extérieur du parti
reste quand même un seul homme de foi
l'accrochage ou alors je crois que le
principal point d'accroc charge tourne
autour du bilan à faire de l'activité de
l'ensemble du public communiste et là il
ya une phrase de georges marchais qui
était beaucoup reprise commentait
discutées et contestées
nous considérons que ce bilan est
globalement positif et je crois
qu'effectivement le problème essentiel
pour le parti communiste veut être là
les critiques qu'il adresse à l'union
soviétique est ce que ce sont des
critiques qui porte sur l'ensemble du
système ou seulement sur ce que l'on
appelle des bavures et je crois que le
fait que l'on se serait traitée comme
les livres salaires mutuellement de
stalinien à l'intérieur de cette réunion
et peut être doublement significatif
cela montre bien où est le point
sensible et cela montre bien aussi que
l'on aborde maintenant le problème de
façon assez différentes
rude semaine pour la sidérurgie
française des coupes sombres annoncées
au moins de la restructuration de cette
industrie en crise ont fini par tomber
elles sont très dures en une semaine
c'est près de 20000 licenciement qui
seront officiellement annoncés avec
jacques manilow maintenant la carte de
france du chômage dans la sidérurgie
ils étaient quelques centaines venues de
boulogne sur mer pour manifester ce
matin à paris contre les 1500
licenciements annoncés aux aciéries de
paris outre une manifestation qui ouvre
une semaine noire de la sidérurgie se
sont en effet quinze à vingt mille
licenciement qui seront prochainement
annoncés au comité d'entreprise
les différents groupes sidérurgiques
premières touchées la lorraine avec 8500
licenciements dans le groupe sacilor ce
lac
le groupe qui perd plus de 2 milliards
par an n'a pas encore fait connaître le
détail de ces licenciements mais on
s'attend à 4095 suppressions d'emplois à
hagondange 2320 à hayange et 1690 à
homécourt toujours en lorraine le groupe
pussy nord châtillon a tranché
aujourd'hui entre la construction d'une
aciérie oxygène à longwy où à neuves
maisons et c'est finalement neuf maisons
qui a été retenu un coup dur pour longwy
où quatre à cinq mille emplois seront de
ce fait supprimer mais ce ne sera
malheureusement pas tous s'attend en
effet à ce que le groupe usinor annonce
plus de 12000 licenciements seront
touchés le valenciennois avec 2 à 3000
suppressions d'emplois à denain émile à
valenciennes d'autres vagues de
licenciements concerneront dunkerque
cause un iceberg qui ont vive
s'ajoute à cela après deux camps la
menace de fermeture de la société
métallurgique de normandie 6000 salariés
dépendant du groupe en pin et oubliés du
plan de restructuration de la sidérurgie
l'ensemble de ces licenciements sera
échelonnée dans le temps entre avril
prochain et la fin de 1981 mais ils
seront plus difficiles à effectuer car
les saisons où il emploie à supprimer
ces deux dernières années ont épuisé la
procédure des retraites anticipées
une réaction de jean-jacques
servan-schreiber ce matin sur europe 1
tout cela
parlons tout cela c'est en grande partie
la faute du plan de bray ferry jacques
ferry président la sidérurgie française
et michel debré mini des finances en 69
après avoir aussi ce soir les
explications du ministre de l'économie
le monsieur rené monory qui sera
l'invité de cartes sur table interrogé
donc par jean pierre elkabbach et alain
duhamel l'indemnisation minimale aurait
reporté à 10 francs 75 au 15 décembre 18
sambre pardon c'est le cnpf et
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
qui viennent de le décider
donc ils portent à dix francs soit 15 au
lieu de 10 francs 30 jusqu alors la
semaine de travail en quatre jours
adopté par les députés vendredi un
projet de loi inadmissible dit la cfdt
et puis l'edf à nouveau des grèves
jusqu'au 20 décembre à l'appel de la cgt
une série de journées d'action pour
obtenir l'ouverture de négociations avec
la direction d'edf sur les effectifs les
salaires et les classifications voilà
nous sortons maintenant de nos
frontières et nous parlons d'abord de ce
qui s'est passé en iran aujourd'hui et
qui est la répétition minutieuse de ce
qui s'est passé hier la même
mobilisation des opposants au chat le
même succès pacifique des manifestations
pour la deuxième journée consécutive
téhéran a connu l'une de ces
manifestations qui font date dans
l'histoire d'un pays
combien est il au juste un million deux
millions de personnes plus peut-être est
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
venue du shah reza longue de 14 km était
noire de monde
jusqu'à la place chariatte grande comme
la place de la concorde
littéralement noyée sous le flot des
manifestants fait la différence d'hier
il nous est très vite apparu que le
défilé d'aujourd'hui qui était beaucoup
plus politique que l'on n'hésitez plus à
attaquer directement le régime avec des
slogans tels que à mort le chat à bas le
bourreau et la police fasciste une
nouvelle fois donc le peuple iranien a
démontré en force
il ne voulait plus de la famille
impériale on serait tenté de dire en
vain quelques heures plus tard l'armée
reprenez position dans les rues de
téhéran le grand deuil chiite était
terminée un jeu politique d'une extrême
importance en vente commence dans la
capitale iranienne
arrestation d'un journaliste france en
pologne philippe rice collaborateurs
désinformation brière s'apprêtait à
quitter le pays
il sera inculpé de diffamation les
syndicats de journalistes demandent bien
sûr la libération de leur confrère le
roi hussein à paris diplomatiquement il
s'agit d'une visite importante car le
souverain jordanien détient une bonne
partie des clés qui permettrait de
débloquer une situation toujours tendue
au proche orient et dans cette partie du
monde
et dans ce domaine ces positions sont
souvent très proches de celles de paris
pour la diplomatie française le roi
hussein de jordanie doit jouer un rôle
primordial dans tout règlement du
conflit du proche orient
la position du souverain hachémite s'est
renforcée après les accords de camp
david et depuis les marchandages entre
le président sadate et monsieur bed-in
les négociations entre l'egypte et
israël but en effet sur un point
essentiel
l'avenir de la cisjordanie cette
cisjordanie perdu par le roi hussein
pendant la guerre des six jours en 1967
sollicité par les états unis et le
président carter le roi hussein n'a pas
voulu se joindre à la négociation égypto
israélienne mais tout de même il ne la
condamne pas il reste prudent
rejetant surtout un accord séparé en
cela sa position est très proche de
celle de la france qui estime que la
paix au proche orient ne peut pas être
fragmentaires mais global brouillé avec
la résistance palestinienne en septembre
1970 depuis plusieurs mois ces relations
se sont améliorées avec l'ol paie et
yasser arafat et ainsi le roi hussein
reste donc un trait d'union entre israël
et les palestiniens et genre ce bad le
disais les négociations de paix entre
égyptiens et israéliens sont toujours en
panne le discours de man and begin il y
à oslo n'a pas contribué à les débloquer
pas plus pour l'instant que ces
premières conversations avec sagesse le
kata d'état mec est venu à jérusalem
pour assister aux funérailles de madame
gold amer funérailles nationales
préparait dans tout le pays
la mère du président carter sera là
demain
on dit aussi qu une haute personnalité
égyptienne pour être également et
assister alain peyrefitte représentera
la france à ses funérailles de madame
gold à merde mais les nouvelles de la
transat française ou plutôt d'alain
colas puisque lui seul manque maintenant
à l'appel ce matin un seul bréguet
atlantique a quitté pointe à pitre pour
une nouvelle mission de reconnaissance
décision qui a provoqué l'envoi par
françois mitterrand d'un télégramme à
raymond barre lui demandant que soient
intensifiés ces recherches
des recherches qui malgré tout reste
méthodique mais déficit bien sûr c'est
un breguet atlantique comme celui ci qui
participent aux recherches à partir de
pointe à pitre mais également depuis les
as ont cet avion est doté d'appareils
détecteur des plus perfectionnés pouvant
capter tous les messages radio
si le manour eva n'a pas coulé ou
simplement des maths et les opérations
de détection sont trouveront facilité
mais le parcours des recherches pour un
breguet sont beaucoup plus aléatoire
dans l'hypothèse du bateau dans la colle
a assombri
et que le navigateur solitaire braillard
dans le cas de la courbe du rhum se
trouve
dans un bar ou d'un dîner dans un radeau
de sauvetage
on est amené à faire une recherche à vue
si nous avons une position précise d'une
enfant du lieu du naufrage nous
conduisons immédiatement une recherche
en terre est coincé quand nous sommes
informés en retard 2
en événements de mai à solvalla la zone
de probabilités une présence devient
considérable en étant mené amène
plusieurs avions d'un des hommes
continuent et chacun 10 ans conduit dans
sa zone
une recherche de ce type
en traîneau jusqu'à 21h30 ce soir heure
française pour l'avion parti des açores
et jusqu'à 23h30 pour celui basé à
pointe à pitre
les recherches se poursuivent mais il
faut bien se rappeler que dans l'océan
atlantique
le deux mâts d'alain colas long de 20
mètres n'est qu'un tout petit point
la page sportive maintenant avec tout
d'abord du ski début des compétitions
internationales chez les hommes hier en
autriche h timing en descente les
canadiens ont pris les deux premières
places et tout de suite derrière eux
plus étonnant un soviétique malgré
l'absence de franz klammer on attendait
une victoire autrichienne hier à
schladming
au cours de la première descente de la
coupe du monde en fait ce fut un
triomphe pour le canada qui placent cap
de ses représentants dans les dix
premiers dont deux aux deux premières
places
le vainqueur s'appelle ken read sa
victoire n'est pas à proprement parler
une surprise
souvent places d'honneur il avait déjà
remporté une descente il y a trois ans à
val d'isère avec lui on a coutume de
dire ça passe ou ça casse
hier il est passé pour l'emporter en une
minute 32 secondes et 11 centièmes
devançant son compatriote murray de six
centièmes et la révélation de l'épreuve
ici sur votre écran le soviétique
makeïeff et les français me direz vous
même si on les attendait pas aux
premières places
il est tout de même inquiétant de
constater que notre meilleur
représentant termine 40 reviennent enfin
un tennis avec la finale de la coupe
davis l'america mcenroe a écrasé le
britannique mottram en trois sets 6-2
6-2 6-1 donnant ainsi aux etats unis une
facile victoire dans la coupe davis 78,4
and john mcenroe 19 ans est bien la
nouvelle étoile du tennis mondial
vainqueur cette année de quatre tournois
du grand prix récemment victorieux du
suédois à borg en demi finale de l'open
de stockholm le jeune américain a
pratiquement assurer à lui seul la 25e
victoire des états unis en finale de la
coupe davis
vendredi dernier il avait d'écraser le
numéro deux britannique john lloyd 6 1 6
nous allons le premier point à son pays
et hier soir dans le match décisif qui
leur ouvraient pas d'acheteur notre fan
tutte si facilement que mcenroe
l'emporter le score 6 2 6 2 6 1 enfin
dans le dernier sac à marianne2 lui
aussi s'est imposé en trois sets
rachel berry tentation aux états unis de
l'emporter par 4 victoires et puis à
mi-chemin entre la performance elle
loisirs départ dimanche prochain du tour
de france à cheval douze cavaliers
hommes et femmes vont effectuer un grand
expo équestre jamais encore réalisé à la
manière des tour de france des
compagnons par tous les temps c'est fou
du cheval vont parcourir 13 mille
kilomètres en un an à raison de 50 km
par jour et ainsi redécouvrir la france
un autre rythme celui lors du tour de
france ne feront pas une compétition ils
veulent démontrer qu'en dehors de
l'équitation traditionnelle pratiquée en
manège
il existe une véritable équitation de
loisir
le plus jeune a 16 ans le plus âgé 44
ans biologiste institutrice maréchal
ferrant électricien secrétaire tous ont
pris un an de congé sans solde pour
vivre l'aventuré ensemble
on se surnommait trop randonneurs et le
responsable de l'expédition
c'est lui qui a sélectionné les
cavaliers au cours d'une épreuve de 4000
km l'esprit d'équipé est ici une qualité
plus importante que la valeur de l'homme
à cheval il s'agit de tout partager
selon l'étape où la saison pendant 12
mois
les cavaliers dormiront dans leurs
caravanes à la belle étoile sous la
tente et aideront le chef dans sa
cuisine roulante
il faut donc pour ce long voyage des
chevaux très résistant la majorité de
nos chevaux viennent de l'étranger
puissent comprendre l'attrait peut
trouver de showkhi qui correspondait à
ce que l'on fait on alors d'arabe de
magnifiques qui viennent de plusieurs
continents en à des novices landais six
chevaux solide le ch'ti qui peuvent qui
vident à la neige qui vivent dehors et
qui ont fait leurs preuves dans
différentes compétitions notamment c'est
ce que j'ai fait aux états unis et qui
est extraordinaire on a déconné marin on
a des croisements barbe barbara brel et
pichot solide et rustique qui au thon
faisait alors pas la majorité des
chevaux et vu la fée 4300 kilomètres en
quatre mois cet été le cheval et son
décès celui ci il a une particularité
unique contrairement à ses frères de
race qui marche aux trois allures le pas
le trot et le galop l'islande et possède
deux avions supplémentaires l'angle et
le theule le tate c'est en quelque sorte
la marche à pied de compétition regardez
bien il n'est pas au trot ils se
déhanchent très vite et peut ainsi
accélérer le pas au maximum cette allure
lui permet d'économiser son énergie tout
en étant très confortables pour le
cavalier
mais la traversée des états unis il y a
deux ans avec tripoli
mais d'autres sont restés bien en
amérique ya quelques passages vitaminés
moi j'ai quitté de carrosserie j'ai fait
le premier exposé comment tricher c'est
le 1000 miles environ 3200 km moi je
fais la deuxième place en tout et le
premier place en meilleure condition
d'aimer deux jours c'est une performance
et une garantie pour ce tour de france
je pense j'espère parce que les sous
qu'on a fait le tour de france
enregistré ni l'islande sont que trois
jours ici et il faut qu suite le
parapluie encore très mal connue chez
nous est considéré un peu comme un
superbe objet de collection
il va pouvoir montrer qu'il est toujours
digne de ses ancêtres ce qui dans le
passé ont permis aux morts où aux
espagnols de devenir des vaudous table
conquérant aujourd'hui on n'utilise plus
les chevaux pour les travaux des champs
ou pour la guerre pourtant l'engouement
à leur égard est resté le même
cela correspond à un besoin suivait deux
ans de la vie de tous les jours de la
civilisation de la société actuelle nous
intéressions besoin de détente un besoin
de nature et que de viande animale
pendant ce tour de france les amateurs
de tourisme équestre pourront à leur gré
se joindre à la caravane après le tour
de france francis herblot préparera un
voyage beaucoup plus long paris moscou à
cheval son but
arrivés à moscou pour l'ouverture des
jeux olympiques
au galop maintenant la météo avant de
refermer ce journal temps généralement
doute aujourd'hui vous le voyez très
doux même pour la saison demain et bien
le temps sera doux couvert et pluvieux
sur la moitié ouest variable et plus
frais ailleurs à noter les rendez vous
de l'information ce soir sur antenne 2
21h30 cartes sur table invité ce soir
rené monory
et puis 23h05 le dernier journal qui
vous sera présenté par pierre alain vous
remercie de votre attention et je vous
souhaite une très très bonne soirée
demain